hey leute fragt sich jetzt mit
sicherheit hey was das für ein video der
bedankt sich bei uns was soll das ich
wollte mich nämlich mal ganz kurz bei
euch und auch bei ein paar anderen
personen dafür bedanken dass sie
einerseits also ihr das konzept dieses
konzept 0 relativ gut angenommen habt
also eigentlich sehr gut das finde ich
sehr schön hat mich sehr gefreut und
auch noch bei ein paar anderen person
oder fange ich einfach direkt mal bei
adsense und er hat mir beim kanal design
geholfen und bei allgemeinen par
grafiken zum beispiel bei facebook hat
er mir ein bisschen hilfe geleistet
bei an ihn möchte ich mich sehr doll
bedanken weil ich finde das eher
allgemein sehr sehr gute kanal designs
macht usw
deswegen sein kann als in der
beschreibung ihr könnt da einfach mal
drauf klickt euch dann durch ein paar
videos klicken vielleicht ein gruß
hinterlassen oder so also danke an dich
dann danke an mein geniales intro an
wille reck ich weiß ich hab da oft rum
gemeckert das ist ja doch falsch sei und
dabei ist am ende doch etwas sehr geiles
bei rumgekommen
also danke an wenn direkt er wird mir
wahrscheinlich auch noch ein intro für
den kontakt machen also dass der auch
schon so ein cooles intro bekommt oder
los also muss ich einfach schauen was
daraus wird
also danke auch an ihn und also kann als
auch in der beschreibung und auch danke
an euch also dass beiden die beiden
waren die personen die wir so bei 3d
sachen und so weiter geholfen haben weil
ich kenn mich da jetzt sich ganz so doll
aus und naja und dann möchte ich mich
natürlich auch noch bei euch bedanken
weil ihr dieses komplett neue konzept am
anfang noch ein bisschen zimperlich
entgegen genommen habt aber mittlerweile
hat sich das bei euch eigentlich ganz
gut eingeprägt also das wirklich in
zweiten tag kommt wöchentlich immer lust
und da komme ich auch schon sofort zu
einem thema und zwar bitte nicht meckern
wenn jetzt mal eine woche
beziehungsweise zwei wochen
letztes wochenende und dieses wochenende
ist jetzt nicht losgekommen
ganz einfach weil ich bin gerade wenn
ihr dieses video seht in paris machte
dort urlaub und habe allgemein in der
woche vor den ferien zwei klausuren
geschrieben muss auf zur fahrschule und
alles möglich also es gerade echt total
stressig bei mir von daher schaffe ich
das nicht immer aber irgendwann wird es
einmal in der woche auch noch eine
lustvoll gegeben und dann würde ich
sagen sind wir einfach alle glücklich
und dann hat sich das erledigt also
bitte da nicht weiter herum meckern
und ja ich wollte mich halt einfach bei
euch bedanken und ich hoffe dass das
weiterhin so gut läuft hier auf youtube
dass ihr weiterhin die videos schaut und
ich würde sagen also ich bin jetzt noch
bis donnerstag in paris ich habe bis
dahin endlich alles hochgeladen
ich hoffe dass sich alles automatisch
veröffentlicht sollten endlich keine
fehler auftreten wird dann würde ich
sagen euch erstmal noch einen schönen
tag und danke